I'm in Paris in the UNESCO building here,
I'm here for the ceremonial opening of the international year of the
periodic table. It started in January,
but now at the end of January is the full opening.
There's been a ceremony with lots of speeches with
ministers, all sorts of important people, making speeches,
Nobel prize winner, and also me.
And then I came to do this unusual way.
I'm good to take you on the tour I office in altering them.
And [inaudible] not all of the,
so finally, to celebrate this,
I want to show you a special video that my colleagues,
which we were not used to in about 10 minutes time.
So much though, I never seen so much of any element.
[Inaudible].
Inserted the cube into the periodic table of the elements to the 10 is
Here. I also found my very first female table.
I have been showered with presence by all sorts of different people.
I've lost count what I've had.
Okay.
This one's really good. This is thin coating of aluminum oxide.
And as you turn it, it changes color.
Also they have a terrific exhibition.
And what I've really liked to do is not so much to,
for you to hear the speeches. You can hear speeches anywhere,
but come and see some of the things in the exhibition.
These are high temperature superconductors,
which if you called them to liquid nitrogen temperature, display,
the so-called Meissner effect and they repel magnets.
So you can make things levitate.
So this must be Mendel leaves flat.
It's his office, I think. Yes. So you can look around and like,
look wherever you look. Wow.
I couldn't see his portraits. And it's quite a,
quite a nice room. Yeah.
I've got the.
Joy that yes, really. Well.
I would rather done the experiment myself, I think, but it was quite fun.
The ball runs nice. Debbie would get really excited at this.
So where are you from
into the water?
Not too crazy.
Mandalay proposed the periodic table for the first time he published it
in 1869. That's 150 years ago.
And not quite three years ago,
it suddenly struck me that the hundred and 50th anniversary would be a great
time for chemists all over the world to celebrate this.
And I suggested it to the president of the international union of pure
and applied chemistry. And then thankfully,
I didn't have to do anything else.
People got really excited and now they've made it happen.
And here I am to enjoy it.
[Inaudible].
Of course I will have a very warm weaponry of Brady being here and keeping me
and older.
But I hope also what I really will remember is
the very warm things that people have said about our videos and how much of it
is helping them to teach chemistry and to enthuse people about the periodic
table.
Like that.
Part two of our video we're in Moscow, in Russia,
we're in a building called the golden brain has strange things on top a bit like
my hair only golden. And there's a huge number of people here.
You can see selfies and Gardner as well.
Look at all these people. How would you cameras up? Look at them all.
What do you think of this professor? You're famous. Wow.
I'm about to sit in men, the lift chair.
It's amazing.
And I suppose this is nearly as close as I can get to Mandalay,
but on the other hand,
it looks as if the test has been covered again with, um,
new material. I suspect his cigarette burn.
So lots of health in this this morning,
I saw a really nice painting. I've seen it before.
My favorite painting of men did at his desk cup of
tea cigarette in hand looking as if he's about to say something really
interesting. So now I'm here noti no cigarette,
but I feel really proud to be here.
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] officer.
[inaudible] what we paid more.
Yes. Is my belt.
[Inaudible].
No, yeah.
At the effective ties, uh,
in my cardiac care specifically.
[Inaudible].
You? Perfect. Are you ready?
And it wouldn't be the periodic table that we noticed that I also,
my very first.
[Inaudible].